hello ladies hello hello can you tell us
why you're here tonight and what have
you won
um well with south africa and we won we
came second in the national finals which
we played
last month a few months ago
yeah why are we here tonight ellie oh
because we were nominated for the award
for best team of the year
and one and you won
it yay
and what what do you think about winning
i think that's like the icing on the
cake of a fantastic year of girls
cricket we were quite shocked i think i
didn't we didn't really expect to win
but
yeah it was a nice nice way to end the
season yeah on a high and start next
season yeah it's kids
and becky you've been part of the demon
games inspired team cricket team manager
for many years many years and you've
been waiting
year after year yeah and what award did
you win tonight
wow a bit of a surprise and the all the
managers got and volunteers and all the
players got um sports personality so
that's very exciting it's a real shock
actually and really nice to we all had a
letter from jerry and that was really
lovely anyway inviting us for the night
and i was coming so i nominated the
girls but actually to get that
recognition as a
you know as a whole partnership event
that was really really cool
thank you and well done to you
and there were a few people here tonight
that can't make it tonight but also need
to be mentioned to say thank you to
their hard work at the
demonstrated with your community college
steve dinner
yeah um who else is missing
he's up at uni yeah there's low i mean
it's a whole
a lot of people get on board and you
know south dakota a lot of the students
are playing in the teams and i think we
fill lots of slots when needed and yeah
it's just great kids with kids playing
sport yeah at all those levels and it's
such a good event and qriket is just so
strong for girls qriket in team bridge
isn't it yeah it's like getting stronger
as we go as well which will be good
because more people start to play itself
so yeah more competition yeah and the
girls you know south afro girls ellie's
now in the england play a pathway oh
yeah yeah we've got come back yeah we've
got a couple others in the county set up
we've got uh some district girls now so
yeah it's going straight to strength and
it's all down to their commitment and us
just enjoying coaching them and spending
time and developing the game that's
really good
well thank you for being here tonight
and congratulations thank you for
inviting us yeah thank you we hope to
see you again next year definitely